thank you way too much credit Diane but
welcome to Horizon and as Diane
mentioned we've been building a hyper
scale cloud and running it for quite a
while and it has over eight applications
powered by this cloud with more than a
billion users right search maps YouTube
and so on and so on and as Diane
mentioned they're the eighth one is
actually TCP Google cloud platform
itself so everyday Google cloud platform
applications not by Google by our
customers touch over a billion different
IP addresses worldwide every single day
so it's really an incredible scale and
that scale requires an incredible
investment I'm very proud that the 10
plus years of investment not just money
but really expertise very hard work by a
very large team is being recognized
today and I want to start off by just
showing you how we're different from
other clouds in a few ways so the first
one diana already mentioned a little bit
is our network it's probably our one of
our biggest areas of investment we have
hundreds of thousands of miles of fiber
that we own the largest fastest highest
capacity submarine cable in the world
for example is was built by Google and
generally speaking you can reach with
this private backbone pretty much any
place on earth so that really means
pretty much any place so for example we
have physical infrastructure in Bhutan
if you don't know what it is look it up
great really wonderful country next we
also have
operated at scale for a very long time
and if you operate on our scale you kind
of realize that efficiency and
performance is important and so we had
lots of time and lots of expertise to
really do that and it shows another GCP
first is the end migration just because
we do maintenance or just because we
have to do an upgrade you shouldn't need
to do anything so on GCP despite us
upgrading things all the time your
workload just keeps running and of
course we provide great value Thank You
Lydia up to fifty nine percent less for
the same workload at great performance
and what's more important we put the
cloud back in cloud because with per
minute billing custom VM types automatic
discounts no worrying about reserved
instances or long-term contracts you
pay-as-you-go
that's what cloud was invented for and
so with our approach to pricing our
user-friendly approach to pricing which
is much easier to do business with so of
course we're improving this product
Diane talked a little bit out the
launches I want to highlight just a few
things that launched in the past few
weeks one was our sequel service v2
it's the highest throughput sequel
service on any cloud automated storage
sizing for sequel so you never run out
of storage space for your database
because we grow it automatically for you
weather data for bigquery if you want to
correlate your data with whether a new
machine learning api's VM right sizing
recommendations to save you money lower
pricing for preemptable VMs resizing of
another first resizing persistent disks
without downtime while your VM keeps
running so it's just a few
of the improvements that we launched in
just the last four six weeks now we see
incredible demand from pretty much
anywhere in the world and to make sure
that all users have a cloud next to them
we're going to have rollout new regions
at a rapid pace in the UK in Germany in
Finland and in India and Singapore and
Australia and Brazil and the last
country Northern Virginia and so we're
actually gonna and this is on top of
Oregon which we rolled out earlier Japan
is coming next week and next month and
starting in 2017 we're gonna roll out
roughly one new region per month and
we're going to keep up that pace for
quite a while so this is just the first
wave of our expansion you're gonna hear
more about the next wave in the coming
months all of these regions are going to
be multi zone so you can run high
availability applications in a single
region and they're going to be connected
by the Google cloud network the largest
private backbone in the world
so your connectivity is gonna be fast no
matter where you are and no matter where
your users are because you can reach
them using the same connectivity that
Google reaches that user all right now I
told you that we're building a different
cloud and I want to tell you a little
bit more but to do that I let me go a
little bit about a history of clouds so
cloud in many ways started about 20
years ago with colocation
colocation let you rent data center
space instead of having to worry about
investing building maintaining running a
data center so that was great and pretty
soon afterwards it went really to the
second wave of cloud were all
this infrastructure was virtualized so
you have the same components
you know servers disks networks you know
whatever low balance but now they're
virtual
not physical and that's great because
what used to be a purchase order now
becomes an API call and poof you have a
new machine or a new disk or a new
whatever and that really transformed how
people to do IT it's a very very deep
impact but it maintained the same
structure of the data center
everything's virtual now but you can
deal with the same components and it's
just as hard to put them together and to
maintain them and to actually keep
things running right so that forces the
user to still focus a lot of their
effort on the wrong things you know do I
have enough servers do they have the
right type data I purchased too much or
maybe too little do I need to have up
grow up great my OS do I have a security
alert all of these things your staff is
forced to to to pay attention to
instead of writing new applications
creating value having innovation
innovative applications and innovative
applications is ultimately how
businesses win how to get new users how
they get new markets how they make their
employees happy so until about ten years
ago we were actually in that same boat
our internal infrastructure looked about
like that and we were struggling with
all of that and we realized that we
can't really maintain our pace of
innovation we can't really be Google if
we don't get out of this complexity so
about ten years ago we really started to
redo our infrastructure we started with
a container based model moving away from
machines and with automated services and
scalable data and that lets our
developers enjoy unprecedented scale
reliability security without worrying
that much about the infrastructure
behind it and this is what we have
brought to Google cloud platform and
that many of you benefit from today let
me just give you a few examples so for
example App Engine Google App Engine
lets you write
you never have to worry about servers
never have to worry about operating
systems you don't even have to worry
about regions zone outages nothing right
you can have an ambitious application
you can run it for a year and you can
have literally and I mean that literally
zero hours on administration or take
another example bigquery or analytic
solution
there's no provisioning of an analytics
cluster there's no maintenance there's
no sizing there's no upgrading just
bring your data and start querying or a
container engine runs your kubernetes
containers without you having to really
administer anything or even for
conventional things like Hadoop clusters
you give you up and running in 90
seconds
having a Hadoop cluster 0 administration
so no ops is really a big step and the
third wave of computing I think needs to
focus on making all of the power of
cloud accessible without you worrying
about the details behind it now Google
was founded with an ambitious mission
organize all the world's information and
that obviously required us to become
experts at handling lots of data right
just for search right for search we have
to store and index and then serve a
private copy of the entire web and we've
been doing that for 15 years we've had
our first trillion line log analyses
running you know sometime in the early
2000s so we've been dealing with big
data for a long time and that forced us
to really pioneer many of the tools and
techniques that are used today in big
data and we're a data-driven business
and so this wasn't just about
infrastructure this was about creating
tools that lets many Google employees
analyze and understand the data that we
have so let me talk a little bit more
about that because externally in Google
cloud platform we took these internal
tools and made them available to you
and they are really making a big impact
to our customers the key tool is bakery
big queries are analytic solution and it
lets you take pretty much an unlimited
amount of data and I mean that literally
and run sequel queries against it and
get results in seconds don't have to
worry about scalability or maintenance
or anything no provisioning no
maintenance zero ups so it's really been
a game changer for many and I'm very
excited today to announce that we have a
major new version of bigquery available
at bigquery for enterprise one of the
key changes in bigquery for enterprise
is that you can now update tables so
that turns it from an analytic solution
into a full data warehouse so bigquery
Enterprise comes with many very nice
features I can mention just a few always
mentioned support for DML so you can do
updates deletes on your data it supports
an SI sequel so all of your tools or
pretty much all of your tools will work
out of the box would be query enterprise
heavy users you can get flat pricing a
predictable bill every month I'll talk a
little bit about more about that
afterwards and of course like all of our
services you have Identity and Access
Management that gives you security and
compliance for your data and access to
your data
we have lots of other features I can't
talk about for example just like in
Google Docs
we tried to make collaboration easy so
sharing queries is as easy as as sharing
a link and of course it's being from
Google it's extremely fast we ask the
third party to run some benchmarks based
on the industry standard at EC pH
benchmarks here's a graph that shows
when multiple users run ttc pH query
number 22 that's already number 10 no
number 22 on 10 terabytes of terabytes
of data sorry
so when you have a few users both
systems are reasonably fast but as you
increase
usage that power and the automatic
scalability of bigquery really starts to
show and at 32 users it's 29 times
faster because bigquery could scale
automatically for you and it scales
independently off the data size so you
get just the right performance at a very
attractive price let me actually
elaborate on that so this high
performance is not come at the penalty
of paying through your nose it's not
just easier to use it's also cheaper to
use now how is that here's another
comparison this assumes that you have a
data warehouse that grows over time and
so you get not just a higher performance
that you just say but you get low
predictable cost because bigquery only
uses resources when you are actually
running queries so let me give you an
analogy it's a little bit like like a
light switch
right so with Amazon redshift you have
to pick a room size and you have to pick
the number of bulbs light bulbs in that
room and then you have to turn it on and
you have to leave it turned on for the
entire month whether you're in a room or
not right and now surprise your bill at
the end of the month is going to be
pretty substantial in comparison
bigquery is kind of a little bit more
like a a motion sensor light switch so
the light goes on when you enter the
room goes off when you leave it
magically the room is just always well
lit in the right size and so no wonder
your bill it can be lower at the end of
the month so you get this scalability
and the zero administration at a much
lower price than comparable solutions so
with that it's really pretty easy to
choose your cloud data warehouse because
really no other data warehouse offers
you a combination of these of these
functionals
functionalities and the the choice
between pay-as-you-go which is ideal for
like users and fixed pricing which is
ideal for heavy users so that much about
analytics and obviously analytics is
really really important
because it lets you take your data and
derive value from it but often machine
learning can actually derive even bigger
valley from that same data now to give
you an example just a few months ago we
applied machine learning to our own data
centers and to the controls of the
cooling system of that data centers and
we were able to save up to 40% of
cooling energy in our data centers by
applying machine learning so it's really
terrific the problem is that machine
learning has a high hurdle to adoption
you need a lot of expertise and a lot of
compute to actually make it work for you
and our goal is to change that our goal
is to democratize machine learning and
to really make it possible for everyone
to use it and how we do that I'll show
you the next few minutes the key to it
is clout machine learning and easiest
way to use client machine learning is to
use complete solutions so we launched a
strong set of machine learning api's
that solve common problems for you for
example here's a sound file
tell me what's spoken in that sound in
that sound file these are trained
machine learning models trained by us
maintained by us fully common as a
service basically bring your data and
get knowledge insight out of it these
been these have been launched throughout
the year and I've actually been some of
our most popular api's ever so usage is
is skyrocketing but on top of having
these canned solutions that solve common
problems you also need to be able to
build your own solution and for that we
created cloud machine learning it went
alpha earlier this year and today I'm
excited to announce that it's now
available to everyone as cloud machine
learning beta comes with a number of
great features first you know should be
no surprise by now that is a no ops
machine learning solution so you don't
have to create a training cluster or a
prediction cluster
choose machine size or you know whatever
you just focus on your problem and once
you have your machine learning model you
just install it and we Auto scale late
for you to arbitrary demand so zero ops
to run and to train your models of
course you get performance as well
so you can do training at scale you get
the full power the parallelized
computing of the google cloud and so
marble-sized is not going to be a
problem it comes with a nice UI as well
you're gonna see that in a demo data lab
it's kind of like a notebook that lets
you develop your code but also document
it and share it very easily and in data
lab you can also manage your your
training runs your your different
versions you can connect to bigquery or
to Google Cloud storage so it's easily
built a full solution not just a a
machine learning model in the last but
not least we have a very special feature
that we call hyper tune it's a little
bit esoteric but when you build a
machine learning model one of the most
important things is to get the model
roughly right but then usually today
that would be followed by days and weeks
of tuning because it's small has a lot
of parameters and you need to find out
which settings actually maximize the
accuracy of your model and Google Cloud
ml hybrid tune does that maximization
for you so we try lots of our versions
in the background and you can accomplish
in an hour what today takes an expert
days or even weeks to get to and you'll
see that a little bit it's really an
incredible time-saver
but rather than me talking to slides
let's actually see that in action I'd
like to invite Rob craft up to the stage
and he's going to give you a demo of a
few different ways how customers use
machine learning Rob over to you thanks
very much for tea
so is my mic on it is on awesome so what
you're looking at is eighty thousand
creative common images that we put
through our vision API service as
mentioned this is a fully trained model
based on a lot of learnings we had
creating Google photos which does an
amazing job about understanding
cognitively what you were showing it in
pixel form so here we mapped eighty
thousand worth and I plugged it into a
nice pretty word cloud that gives you an
idea on how these things map that makes
sense to people and then we have a
couple images to the side that kind of
shows you a little bit of the power so
the first is the recognition and forgive
me for the analogy but the Internet is
powered with cats and here is a cat to
prove it
hers is has private islands bought with
cat money I think at this point so
there's two things that are important
here one is that we're successfully
labeling on the side what the image is
and as you might suppose close up
faraway color of long hair short hair
looking at camera not looking at camera
you have to have a pretty sophisticated
understanding of visualization systems
they get this sort of thing correct but
you want to know how correct it is
because it could be a business decision
you never believe anyone without data of
course if you're running a successful
business so on the side here we're
giving you an indication of how certain
we are so we're 99% sure it's a cat and
it's 83% sure it's a domestic Shorthair
we give you lots of other information
like the color palette for those of you
with brand sensitivity for colors and
textures and feels for your advertising
campaigns this matters a lot and it's
really hard to get and we offer a lot of
other data like is it inappropriate
content ninety percent of the new data
arriving near business is unstructured
data like this it's voice it's audio
it's in a language that you don't speak
it's directly from a customer it's about
your brand on the internet that you
can't find yourself systems like this
drastically change the capability to
understand how people are talking about
you how you would like to be talking how
to be talked about and as well as what
imagery matters we also do it for the
other languages in capabilities so let
me do one more and I'll flip over to
another demo this one is pretty excited
for those of us like sports
on the surface for those of us from the
US this is very obviously a baseball
stadium computer can't make that
assumption so we start from scratch we
don't believe you when you label this as
a baseball stadium for example because
it turns out people aren't always
necessarily truthful on the Internet I
know it's are surprising but there we
are so it's a stadium it's a team sport
we're even picking up some baseball
equipment you see the little picture in
the background the guy holding the
baseball bat we picked up that it's a
baseball bat not just a stick and here's
the part that I'm especially proud of
not only do we grab the text on all the
signage in the background and we're
offering bounding boxes soon so you can
pick what area of the image you want to
look at but we identified out of all the
baseball stadiums this is City field
so that capability applied to landmarks
using the power of what we learned from
maps and other systems becomes available
to you and to do one of these images is
literally six lines of code so this
vastly changes the world around what
machine learning can provide versus the
work you think you have to do to get
machine learning benefits in your
applications okay so we're done everyone
ready to do their first neural network
let's do a neural network this will be
fun so we're going to start with
something that matters a lot for this
room let's predict whether the sp500
gonna close up or down in this case
we're gonna take 50 years plus worth of
data across thirty two hundred stock
tickers we're gonna combine it using
some training information across other
pieces pump it through a neural network
and out the other side is going to come
a prediction this identifies what a lot
of people on your businesses are doing
today or that you'll be asked to do
going forward which is create your own
model so we're using the Google Data Lab
tool that is mentioned a little bit
earlier it's a notebook that has compile
you can actually compile queries and do
visualizations natively in here an
example of a visualization of the
dataset is here you can see that it's a
little bit noisy so we're gonna
precondition some data to clean it up
much tighter distribution on data set so
we're gonna learn faster with our model
and what does a model look like well in
this case pardon the the lingo dropped
but I need to show that it's a real
thing it's a feed-forward neural network
for hidden layers thousand twenty four
nodes per layer we're doing rectified
linear Nuits between and then we have a
soft max regression long way to way of
saying this is a reasonable demo at any
production so please don't do too
based on the numbers you're gonna see at
the bottom I said it I am NOT
responsible so this is a prettier
picture for those of us that forget
everything that I just said it's a
reasonable explanation of what we're
trying to do this is how Earth's the
code is the tooling and machine learning
is really really hard we're doing it
better we're making it more simple the
fact that it isn't scribbled on a napkin
or a whiteboard and erased as soon as
that your data scientists leave the room
is a big step forward for the
marketplace and we're going to continue
to improve the experience let me get to
kind of the the money and the power here
use cloud ml because it takes a long
time to train let me skip right to the
money shot it's a hundred and twenty
three hours to do what I just explained
on roughly a developer workstation class
machine come back in five days and you
get your answer come back in five days
and get your answer and then begin
iteration wait another five days or
argue about it for three days and then
come back in another five days welcome
to a machine scientist nightmare that's
the state of the art today by just
changing one line you say I want to run
it on premium instance I don't configure
any more machines come back in three
hours and if you want to go more we can
go more if you'd like don't contact me
directly we have people so now you enter
into the interesting space of it's okay
but not great the accuracy isn't what I
want it's sixty percent and I'm not
gonna make a business decision on 60
percent if only there were a wand with
some magic pixie dust in it well it's
not quite magic pixie dust it's a lot of
PhD sweat and tears that gone into it
but hyper tuned allows you to
automatically tune the aspects for the
model that may not be learning or
asymptotic towards the result that
you're asking for the model to predict
against so through one simple change of
code
it literally is one line of code and if
you're up can find it quickly there we
go
jobs trainer tasks off you go and you
get the machine now spinning up multiple
multiple instances running multiple
experience at once picking which one is
maximizing towards the prediction that
you want and rendering an answer so
there's what you need to do if you're a
data scientist with cloud ml I encourage
you to compare to what your current data
scientists get to use it's a lot
different proposition so this is if you
create your own let's see what someone
actually created themselves so we have a
used car
customer in Japan and what they're
trying to do and this is a real example
this is the model they created not
Google they allowed us to demo for them
is they wanted to better understand what
they just bought at auction or what they
would like to put on sale at auction in
Japan so we have a whole series of
images to the side imagine I'm a
used-car salesmen it took a bunch of
pictures of the vehicle and I just would
like it to go up on the auction site
immediately without me tediously
identifying what the image was front and
rear what the model was getting it wrong
so let me go ahead and select all my
camera real I'm gonna drop it directly
onto the application let me minimize and
you'll see these bits are actually going
to a hosted instance in our new Tokyo
data center but you see it actually
beginning to do some analysis this takes
about 30 seconds and I've been
threatened with my life if I go too long
so let me flip over to the answer that
you can see in 30 seconds we're 89% sure
we being the used car company this is a
2012 toyota land cruiser prado that's
not available in the US by the way it's
anywhere from 39 to 43 thousand
currently at auction because we're
combining other data sources in the
background and the images have been
correctly identified right side left
side quarter panel interior stick shift
control panel you get the idea
drastically changing the experience but
it's not machine learning in your face
so you can train your own models using
pretty simple tools at Google scale and
I hope that you found that interesting
thank you
thank you rob
so that's really great you can see that
actually as a company dealing with very
physical objects like cars you can make
use of much more data with cloud ml this
graph here shows the adoption of machine
learning at school and as people
discover the power and as the tools get
better you can really see usage explode
so today it's used in pretty much every
Google application and our goal with
cloud ml is that the adoption rate in
your company of machine learning looks
like this because tools are getting
easier and more powerful to use let's
actually look at another example a real
world example of one of our customers
using cloud machine learning and so
please welcome Matias Ortner from Airbus
yes so for a little bit of background
Matias been working on image analysis
for the past 15 years for Airbus a
company with 38,000 employs 13 billion
euros of revenue working in all kinds of
areas in air and space but today we're
talking about satellite imagery
commercial satellite imagery so so
Matias tell us a little bit about about
the problem that you were facing well
basically we are selling satellite
images and we want to provide our
customers with you know high quality
images and that means we don't want to
have clouds within the image because you
have clouds the bottom is hidden because
we're looking from the sky from the
space and the customer won't pay for
such an image so what we're doing is
which white figure out in the end if we
have clouds within each image we are
saying so ok here you have an example
maybe you can try to guess all you have
a solution but you can see sometimes can
kind of hard sting with clouds from the
sky that's right all right so the image
actually shows how difficult this is
this shows a bunch of mountains
mostly white is snow but actually in the
upper right if you look really closely
it's not snow it's clouds so that
actually sounds like an interesting
problem I assume Airbus been working
this for a while is this an easy problem
or that's a point actually we've been
working on that for 20 years and we try
to be very smart I have to say no to
Matic solution that's proven to be
reliable enough and every day we have
human operators drawing cloud masks on
every single image we download from our
satellites and it's large because we are
downloading thousands of images every
day so you know that's what Boris to use
machine learning and try to figure out
what can be done with this new
technology so that's that's a pretty big
job if you look at this just this
picture it will take you a while to be
accurate about you know what's the cloud
and then just imagine thousands of
pictures so I can tell you how you're
you want to have an improvement and and
while you try cloud machine learning
well did it work for you well yeah well
I started to use machine learning like
five years ago and we had some success
on several several problems and we
started to use a cloud machine learning
on this specific topic beginning of this
year and we had tremendous results so
yeah sure
well our previous automatic solution had
an error rate around 11 percent so
that's a lot and that's what we need
these human operators you know to just
roam cloud mask on the images and we
achieved a three percent error rate
using tensorflow and cloud ml which is
much better we now have a solution for
our problem this is a new situation and
West I think what is most impressive for
us and for everybody in this room is it
took us only three months to reach this
point which is you know much faster than
what we used to have in previous
developments that's I think very
impressive that is really impressive yes
how was your experience with with Google
overall not just cloud ml but but but
Google cloud per se well it's very
positive
or people you know we were very reactive
both commercial and technical teams
we're really helping me on our teams you
know to just get focused and what you
have to do under the cover of our
business I mean really great experience
people were very dedicated hard workers
thank you
so what's next for you and for Airbus
well first of all we are now
investigating how to put this algorithm
into production that's the first step
and now we have seen that you can solve
all problems we have plenty of ideas we
want to you know bring added value to
our customers and we will for sure you
as machine learning in several products
in the coming years okay so you're
probably I mean clearly what's
successful for you and and and your you
started using the alpha version so are
you a few months ahead of everyone else
who can try the beta today if there's
one or two things that you would would
give us advice to our audience what
would you pick well well I think
something really new is happening now
and I mean I mean this problem I've been
working on it you know like six years
ago three years ago and you couldn't
find any solution or no machine learning
can solve problem that couldn't be
solved before that's the first point and
I think it's not only about bringing new
services or new stuff it's also about
our day to day job our engineering work
is no changing and going further quickly
all right thank you very much
it's really amazing congratulations
so I just want to recap that cuz it's
really an amazing story this is a hard
problem very clearly but it will be hard
for any one of us to to go and pick
clouds on these images they've been
working on it for literally two decades
and in three months with our alpha
version you know Matthias was able to
beat the existing system by a factor of
four in error rate right that's truly
amazing and I actually want to leave you
with one more thought because those of
you old enough to remember might
remember that about ten years ago
Netflix had a competition to wait for
with a million dollar price to
researchers out there anyone could
participate to predict what movies
you're gonna like based on a set of
existing movie ratings and the best
researchers hundreds of teams across the
world competed in that competition and
after three years someone want the the
the million dollar prize an amazing
thing is that today with Google Cloud ml
in one day you can build a model that
would be competitive in that in that
competition and I bet that in under a
month you could build something that
would win right so that is how much the
field has changed just ten years ago
less than ten years ago only the world's
best experts strongly for three years
could do something and today actually
you have a fair chance to meet or beat
these results because the tools have
gotten so much better so if you've been
thinking about machine learning now's
really a good time to start trying it
out so now let me just recap a little
bit what we talked about today right I
hope I can then see that we're building
a different kind of cloud one that's
really oriented around making it much
easier to use all of the capabilities
move away
moving away from virtualized hardware
- scalable services scalable data and I
hope I've shown you that with the new
version of bigquery scalable data got
even easier you have a data warehouse in
a cloud zero admin infinitely scalable
at a superb price and with superb
performance and your choice of whether
you want to have variable pricing or
fixed pricing and then beyond that I
hope that mattias just convinced you or
the the the the the other demos that
machine learning really today is within
reach for most companies if you use
Google Cloud ml even in its beta version
in fact even in its alpha version it can
deliver incredible valley to you and
obviously we're spending an enormous
amount of time on making these tools and
the infrastructure behind it better
every single day so it only will get
easier in the future now so that's the
true power of this next-generation cloud
because you can focus on on insights on
creating valley from your data not on on
orchestrating and administering all that
stuff